[Musique]
rêver
rêver fait appel à quelque chose qu'on a
dans son cœur quelque chose de secret
quelque chose d'intime
l'évolution quant à elle et quelque
chose qui doit être visible de tout le
monde qui doit être partagé
que tout le monde doit s'approprier et
qu'on doit voir c'est comme les forêts
qui poussent
la révolution
se mélangent entre le secret
et le visible doit être une véritable
explosion
je suis Nabilla je suis né en 1966 à
Abidjan je suis ivoirien
beaucoup d'entre vous savent ce que je
fais peut-être mais très peu savent qui
je suis
je vais donc vous relever quelques
secrets aujourd'hui et je vais vous
demander bien sûr de le garder pour vous
parce que ce sont des secrets de famille
ce sont des secrets que j'ai dans le
coeur et je vais vous ouvrir mon coeur
je vais vous dire ce qu'il y a dedans
je vais vous dire où je passe mes plus
belles nuits
mais plus belle nuit je les passe à la
belle étoile
dans mon village
à welguécart dans le nord de la Côte
d'Ivoire dans la région du turlogo à
quelques kilomètres de faire caisser de
goût
quand dans ce petit bois à l'écart du
village avec mes parents nous nous
retrouvons la nuit autour de ce feu
sacré
et nous parlons nous parlons de la vie
et nous essayons de transmettre aux
jeunes générations les traditions et
surtout l'art de comment devenir un
homme
mais plus belle journée je les passe
avec mes collaborateurs partout en Côte
d'Ivoire quand nous allons tous ensemble
équiper et former des jeunes
agriculteurs et agricutrices à la
mécanisation agricole parce que c'est
mon métier quand on retourne cette terre
de Côte d'Ivoire où je suis né
je me sens bien et pour cela avec nos
équipes on va partout en Côte d'Ivoire
dans toutes les régions
mon inspiration
mon inspiration je la prends à la
Fondation Amadou en Pathé bar quand dans
cette petite bibliothèque riche de 30
000 manuscrits encore inconnus encore
pas diffusé je m'approche de ce savoir
véritable
montagne de connaissance véritable puis
de sagesse c'est là c'est là que je
prends mon inspiration
ma famille je lui rends hommage au grand
cimetière d'Abidjan
ah Williamsville
quand je vais sur la tombe de mon
arrière-grand-mère que j'ai bien connu
qui est né en 1890 au Caire et qui très
vite est venu au Sénégal puis en Côte
d'Ivoire
sur la tombe de ma grand-mère
qui est née en 1910 à Dakar qui a
profondément marqué mon enfance qui
était une femme très engagée et dont la
devise était aime le pays où tu vis
elle était fortement engagée
elle avait nous montré souvent ces
petites cartes que je vous montre et qui
sont à l'écran
elle était membre du Parti démocratique
de Côte d'Ivoire du Rassemblement
démocratique africains et cette carte
comme vous le voyez date de 1957
ma grand-mère Marie
nous parlait de son pays et quand elle
nous parle de son pays nous parlait de
la Côte d'Ivoire
en 1957 la Côte d'Ivoire n'était pas
indépendante mais elle était fortement
engagée elle était là présente active
dans tous les milieux de Côte d'Ivoire
bien sûr après l'indépendance
vous voyez la cotisation annuelle était
de 100 francs à l'époque
les temps ont changé
pour la petite anecdote
nous avons toujours la même boîte
postale on a juste rajouté 0,1 devant
parce que c'est la première qui a été
faite à Abidjan c'est la grande poste au
Plateau
mon réconfort est à côté d'elle
se trouve mon grand-père
qui lui est né en 1905 au Liban et qui
est arrivé dans les années 30 en Côte
d'Ivoire
un peu plus loin je rends hommage à mon
père
à son frère mon oncle à sa sœur ma tante
qui sont tous nés à Abidjan dans les
années 40 tous qui ont tous fait l'école
ici
mon réconfort je le trouve chez ma maman
qui est là dans la salle elle
[Applaudissements]
elle vient de Bretagne à la Bretonne
elle a suivi mon père dans les années 60
en Côte d'Ivoire
et l'ont entouré de mes frères de mes
enfants de mes neveux qui eux sont tous
nés à Abidjan
la Côte d'Ivoire est un merveilleux pays
mon pays est un merveilleux pays qui a
su accueillir
tous les gens venant de partout
et vous savez ce qu'il y a
d'extraordinaire dans mon histoire
familiale
c'est qu'elle est tout à fait ordinaire
et vous tous dans cette salle vous tous
qui êtes présent dans cette salle vous
venez de quelque part vos parents
viennent de quelque part vos
grands-parents viennent de quelque part
du Bénin du Togo du Sénégal du Mali du
Burkina
nous sommes tous présents sur terre et
en même temps nous sommes tous des
étrangers sur terre
nous venons tous de quelque part
et n'oublions jamais ce que ma
grand-mère disait aime le pays où tu vis
Amadou en Pathé bar
[Musique]
avait une formidable
citation
qui disait que demain que la beauté d'un
tapis tient à la variété de ses couleurs
la diversité des hommes des cultures et
des civilisations fait la beauté et la
richesse du monde
la Côte d'Ivoire mon pays est riche de
cette beauté là riche de ses rencontres
on a dit beaucoup de choses dans ta
débat on a dit que c'était un écrivain
un anthropologue un traditionaliste on
dit beaucoup de choses
il y a peut-être une chose qu'on n'a pas
dit
c'est qu'il pouvait prophétiser les
choses il pouvait voir dans l'avenir et
en même temps qu'il nous parlait de ce
tapis de cette beauté de ce tapis il
nous mettait en garde aussi
et il nous disait à nous à nos enfants
que cette génération du 21e siècle
connaîtra une fantastique rencontre de
race et d'idées
selon la façon dont elle a assimilera ce
phénomène elle assurera sa survie ou
pauvretera sa destruction par des
conflits meurtriers
ma vie a changé en novembre 2004
j'ai vécu un drame la Côte d'Ivoire mon
pays avec eu un drame
avec ma famille chez moi
nous avons été attaqués
violenté
chasser
par nos voisins
moi qui me prenais pour un Ivoirien
qui a fait des classes dans des collèges
publics j'étais même boursier à l'époque
qu'on ne donnait 12000 francs par
trimestre pour ceux qui s'en rappellent
pour ceux qui se rappellent on nous
donnait 12000 francs et enchanté l'hymne
national par cœur tous les lundis matins
je n'ai pas compris
les classes où je pouvais être le seul
blanc
parce que mon crime en novembre 2004
c'est d'être blanc
ce crime
je ne l'ai pas compris je l'ai très mal
vécu ça a duré des années
mais je n'ai pas été le seul à le subir
beaucoup d'autres l'ont subi pas
seulement par la couleur de leur peau
mais parfois par leur patronyme
parce que leur nom
apparemment vient de l'étranger
du Bénin du Burkina
en pâte et pas nous mettiez en garde
nous allons vivre une époque fantastique
mais si nous ne faisons car sinon nous
prenons en garde nous aurons à faire à
des destructions à des conflits
l'histoire de 2010 le confirme
[Musique]
je rêve je rêve de cette révolution pour
mon pays
je rêve que plus jamais ce genre de
chose n'arrive
[Musique]
je rêve que nous creusons que nous
prenions très au sérieux toutes les
personnes qui dans des discours de
campagne peuvent stigmatiser l'autre en
disant son nom ne sonne pas bien
il vient de quelque part mais nous
venons tous de quelque part
nous irons tous quelque part
et protégeons nos enfants parce que nous
savons pas où ils iront
nous ne savons pas où ils vivront dans
l'avenir
aujourd'hui la Côte d'Ivoire est une
terre d'accueil
je rêve de ce rêve ivoirien
on voit ce qui se passe dans les pays à
côté on aura encore plus de monde en
Côte d'Ivoire
qui vont venir se réfugier
c'est la patrie de la vraie fraternité
nous dit notre hymne national et nous ne
devons pas l'oublier
mon rêve est simple c'est le rêve d'un
père de famille c'est le rêve d'un papa
je reprends pour moi et peut-être que
vous allez dire que je manque
d'originalité mais je reprends pour moi
ce rêve de ce grand homme de ce père
avant toute chose qui s'appelait Martin
Luther King et qui a dit i have a dream
je rêve qu'un jour mes enfants vivront
dans un pays où ils ne seront pas jugés
par la couleur de leur peau mais par la
force de leur conviction et de leur
caractère
je rêve que ce tapis dont parle à matou
en Pathé bar soit un tapis volant où on
sera tous assis dessus et on volera au
sommet de cette fraternité universelle
que la Côte d'Ivoire puisse être reconnu
dans le monde entier mieux que les
États-Unis parce que n'ayant pas de
complexe comme une terre d'accueil une
perte d'espérance et elle nous
appartient à nous de le mettre en action
il nous appartient à nous de nous lever
contre les injustices de crier très fort
non
c'est facile de dire oui les béni-oui il
y en a beaucoup mais la force de dire
non je ne l'accepte pas je
regroupe plus que qui m'a faibli parce
que ce pays nous appartient tous et
quand on m'a pillé vous savez ce que
j'ai fait et bien je suis resté
chez moi en Côte d'Ivoire parce que je
n'avais nulle part où aller je ne
pouvais pas aller quelque part parce que
c'est ici mon pays c'est ici que je vis
[Applaudissements]
mais cette révolution
nous devons la faire dans l'amour dans
la paix dans la fraternité
jamais dans la violence parce que dans
ce mot révolution il y a aussi
le mot amour
il y a le mot amour dans révolution
[Applaudissements]
il y a alors
alors je remercie devant vous tous ma
grand-mère qui nous disait toujours aime
le pays où tu vis parce que c'est là ton
pays et nous devons tous prendre ça y
voit rien ou non n'y voit rien on doit
se sentir fier d'être en Côte d'ivoire
on doit se sentir fier d'être ivoirien
ne pas avoir honte qu'on a un patronyme
qui vient soi-disant d'un pays étranger
c'est quoi un pays étranger aujourd'hui
au moment où les voyages ou le monde est
un village
il y a un chiffre qu'il faut faire
attention qu'il faut retenir pour la
Côte d'Ivoire dans le dernier
recensement c'est que 53% de la
population est
urbaine
vit en ville
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de mieux que de
brasser des populations dans une ville
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de mieux que des
rencontres
dans une ville
53% on n'est plus un pays rural et pour
ça il faut que nous nous aimions il faut
que nous fassions cette révolution dans
l'amour
merci ma grand-mère merci Marie aime le
pays où tu vis je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]